so this air B&B this is this is where
you come to work yes because you've been
doing is it gold ADR I think it's called
ADR well yeah that's right yes
so ADR is automatic dialogue replacement
and it's the final process of filmmaking
where we clean up this the sound of the
of the picture and and so we haven't
been able to do that because we're all
in kovat and so we have made history by
by doing zoom ADR and post with seven
people in different locations on zoom
running a post operation and they sent
me a my own little ADR studio over here
which do you want to see yeah go on yeah
that's that's an ex of a tour so this is
the this the system it's a computer and
it's a mixing a little mixer and that
runs to this which is my my little audio
studio the microphone the monitor and of
course the pillows that dead in all the
bouncing sound and usually this whole
thing is covered with a Down blanket a
down comforter to to deaden the sound of
the room so we get that nice beautiful
clear sound that they can manipulate
anywhere they want no one is ever going
out to work again are they now that we
know we can do it from home buddy I will
never do
disposable travel again this is the only
way you'll ever get me there unless I'm
on a vacation
[Music]
you